Speaker 1: Welcome, everybody.
Want to go through a couple of clips I spotted
over the last week, bookmarked them, didn't
end up having time to talk about these earlier
in the week.
First one is of everybody's best friend, former
judge.
Yeah.
And Republican Congressman Louie Gohmert,
who I just don't know how this guy manages
to get himself to work every day with the
things he seems to believe and be confused
by.
During a recent hearing, Congressman Louie
Gohmert asked whether the Bureau of Land Management
might be able to change the orbit of the moon
in order to deal with climate change once
and for all.
Let's take a look at this now.
The premise is that the moon's orbit is changing,
and that's true.
We know that that's that's an absolutely true
thing.
The moon is slowly drifting away from Earth
at something like a three point eight centimeters
per year.
And that's something we've seen over the last,
you know, couple few billion years or so.
And Louie's idea is maybe the forest management
and Bureau of Land Management Agencies, they
could just change the moon's orbit even further.
OK, here's the here's the clip.
And check out the reaction from us, Jennifer
Silberstein.
It's just perfect.
Speaker 2: And I understand from what's been
testified to the Forest Service and the BLM,
you want very much to work on the issue of
climate change.
I was informed by the past director of NASA
that they have found that the moon's orbit
is changing slightly and so is the Earth's
orbit around the sun.
We know there's been significant solar flare
activity.
And so is there anything that the National
Forest Service or BLM can do to change the
course of the moon's orbit or the Earth's
orbit around the Sun?
Obviously, that would have profound effects
on our climate.
Speaker 3: I would have to follow up with
you on that one, Mr. Gohmert.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, if you figure out a
way that you in the Forest Service can make
that change, I'd like to know also, just to
put on your radar,
Speaker 1: that reaction is is just something
else.
It's sort of, you know, when a kid says, I
want to make a dinosaur and you say, yeah,
let's check that out, Jimmy.
Let's let's look into that.
That sounds interesting.
This is painfully dumb.
And this this is up there like with Donald
Trump wanting to nuke a hurricane or something
like that, like how how do we even analyze
this other than to say, is it scarier that
this guy is currently a member of Congress
or is it scarier that this guy used to be
a judge, maybe member of Congress?
Because I don't know what the rules are for
judges in Texas, but if you're just appointed,
I don't know.
Let me put it this way.
It's an open question.
What's scarier that this guy is a congressman
or that he was a judge?
I would go even further.
I would say don't have the forest managers
deal with this.
Just use that Jewish space laser that Marjorie
Taylor Green was talking about.
And, you know, Louise, real mistake is it's
not Bureau of Land Management that's going
to change the orbit.
You've got to talk to the Department of Housing
and Urban Development.
That's really who's going to be able to get
involved and and change that lunar orbit.
Just wacky and bizarre stuff.
And this guy is one of four hundred and thirty
five elected members of Congress.
He has one of four hundred and thirty five
privileged votes that determine so much about
the lives of everyday Americans.
Not a good
sign
for
the country, that's for sure.